former bachelorette Andi Dorfman
seemingly claps back at ex-fiance Josh
Murray after he slammed her tell-all
memoir on Monday's episode of bachelor
in paradise
we had very very different values and
we're just very different in a lot of
different ways she has not so kind
things to say it's very unfortunate that
she would depict me in such a like such
a false way first here's some quick
background Andy and Josh got engaged on
the finale of her season of The
Bachelorette in 2014 they broke things
off in January 2015 and Andy went on to
write a book earlier this year telling
her side of the story about why they
decided to split the former baseball pro
had this to say about Andy's claims I
can't comment on specific things that in
any kind of book that my ex has written
because it's a fictional story
there's stuff that's so ludicrous how do
you comment on something like that
now Andy is speaking out seemingly in
response to her former flame she tweeted
on Tuesday quote I speak two languages
English and truth ET spoke with the 29
year old attorney in May she explained
why she wanted to share her story with
the world we always see these couples
that make it but the majority of us
don't make it and I kind of wanted to
take viewers on that journey
you